now say my name
Johnson you're goddamn right
hello Internet welcome to film theory a
daily part of your balanced breakfast
breakfast so go ahead and pour yourself
some cereal and double-check your stevia
for ricin cuz today we're forever
changing the way you look at the final
scene of one of the greatest television
shows of all time as such consider this
your spoiler alert no Breaking Bad is
one of my favorite television shows one
that truly pushed storytelling on TV
main character Walter White's
transformation from a mr. Rogers esque
chemistry teacher to a method kingpin of
Scarface level proportions is perhaps
the most memorable character arc in
television history and what other
televised drama can attest to starting
so many memes from I am the one who
knocks - my personal pick yes science
the characters the acting the pacing the
artistic camera shots everything about
this show was perfect well except for
one thing the ending admittedly ending
such an incredible show was an
impossible task there was no way it
could satisfy everyone I mean Walter
White was a character you either love to
hate hate it - love love - love thou'rt
be hated to hate there was no middle
ground with this guy and after six
swords I guess five and a half
mind-blowing seasons Breaking Bad ended
with what a lot of people thought was a
cop-out after getting complete closure
apologizing to his wife Skyler ensuring
his children get the remainder of his
drug money killing off the rest of the
bad guys and rescuing his partner Jesse
Walt dies from a combination of a
gunshot wound to the abdomen and his
returning cancer all while surrounded by
his beloved meth making equipment in
short the problem a lot of people had
with his ending is that wall
it's everything he wins there is no
punishment or atonement from all of the
awful things he does throughout the
series and let's be honest he does a lot
of awful things sure you may say oh he
dies but he dies on his terms it's a
complete victory for Walter White and
that understandably frustrated people
but what if I told you there was more to
the story that Walt will face trial and
punishment for his crime
set the ending wasn't as cliched and
clean-cut as we've all been assuming the
last couple years in short are we really
sure that the man known as Heisenberg is
dead in that final shots cuz let me tell
you I've run the numbers and he's not I
mean yeah he does get a gnarly stomach
wound collapses and lies motionless on
the floor for about 20 seconds as we
hear some appropriate blue meth inspire
two jabs but is that enough for us to
hang our fierce coats up and accept that
he's dead not a chance
god damn right ha ha gets me every time
okay so what am I talking about well
according to the University of Maryland
Medical Center the three most important
factors for determining a person's odds
of surviving a gunshot wound are one the
location of the injury to the amount of
blood lost and three how quickly the
victim is transported to a hospital so
let's take them point by points but
before we dive into the location of the
injury we first need to discern the
nature of the injury itself and I know
what you're thinking it's a bullet in a
stomach right well not exactly
let's recap the final showdown Walt
comes to the neo-nazi compound with an
automated remote-controlled turret built
into his trunk he tackles Jesse to the
ground clicks the button the trunk pops
open and a barrage of bullets killed
almost all the neo-nazis inside but what
we're most interested in is near the end
of the attack when Walt gets hit by
something I mean it's kind of hard to
tell honestly all we really do is see
him grunt now we know from the opener of
season 5 episode 1 that Walt purchased
an m60 machine gun with 7.62 millimeter
NATO rounds pretty heavy-duty machinery
as evidenced by the fact that it blasted
through the side of the trunk and the
wall of the neo-nazi wreck
like it was nothing but let's look at
the setup here it's highly unlikely that
Walt was actually hit by one of these
bullets first Walt is too low to the
ground Walters hoopty of death is a
fifth-generation Cadillac DeVille which
according to the manufacturer stands
exactly 56.7 inches tall or about 1.4
meters if we take this photo of Walt
standing outside the car and apply some
basic algebra and pixel counting we can
conclude that the trunk is forty point
five inches off the ground or slightly
over one meter the m60 shoot slightly
lower than the exact height of the trunk
so let's just say it's an even 39 inches
about one meter just to be safe
considering that the average width of a
human being is about nine point five
inches or 24 centimeters even if Walt
and Jesse were planking on top of each
other toe to toe forehead to forehead
they would still be far lower than the
line of fire I mean you can even see the
difference from the bullet holes in the
wall compared to their relative position
on the ground so obviously it's not a
direct bullet hit maybe it's a ricochet
seems like a solid possibility except
for one thing according to my research
it seems that higher powered bullets
like a 7.62 millimeter NATO round tend
not to ricochet they usually either
crush into the object they hit or break
of parts ricochets are much more common
with low caliber ammo such as a 22 or
177 the most likely culprit for injuring
Walt then is either shrapnel or a broken
piece of a bullet entering from Walters
side by the side well because throughout
the ensuing scenes we get a pretty good
glimpse at the front and back of Walt's
jacket and there simply aren't any holes
so the right side is the only option
okay
so we have a piece of shrapnel entering
Walt's love-handle knowing this let's
look at our medical criteria number one
the location of the wound we never
actually get to see the wound itself
only the blood stain on the lower right
side of his shirt which is such a shame
because I really love that shirt on
Walt's given the radius of the blood
stain we can only make an educated guess
as to where the entrance wound is the
biggest risk associated with a bullet
wound to the abdomen is hitting either
the lower aorta or some of the major
blood vessels
if such was the case though Walter would
have keeled over and bled to death very
quickly but that's not what happens
Walter walks talks and even tells Lydia
that he murdered her
relative grace for over ten minutes now
you could potentially write off a lot of
waltz mobility as shock but even shock
can keep you alive for ten minutes if a
vital organs been hitting your body no
given the location of blood on wall
shirt it's likely that the shrapnel got
lodged somewhere in his large intestine
and believe it or not this is actually
good news quotes the main concern with
gunshot wounds that involve the
intestines or stomach is not bleeding
but infections that result from spillage
of the contents of those organs and
quotes in other words were dead but it
takes days to die for you a study
conducted by the medical journal the
annals of surgery looked at victims of
gunshot wounds to the abdomen over a
period of five years between 1983 and
1987 the survival rate among victims
that had no vital organs hit was an
astounding eighty eight point three
percent that's incredibly high and with
medical technology having only gotten
more advanced over the last 30 years
vaults would have a real chance at
survival which means we should move on
to the second criteria amount of blood
lost now blood loss is likely the factor
that causes wall to collapse onto the
ground and stare blankly up at the
ceiling but the big question here is
whether he died due to the blood loss or
merely passed out well let's take a look
although we can't realistically measure
the amount of blood that's dripped on to
the ground or absorbed onto Walt's
clothes we can draw some encouraging
conclusions due to the fact that there's
no blood on the other side of his shirt
which means the bullet didn't go through
him exit wounds leave a much bigger hole
than entrance wounds thereby leading the
victim to bleed to death much faster in
other words this fact buys Walt some
valuable time now one thing that I
haven't brought up that I'm sure is on
the tip of all your serous tongues is
that Walt's lung cancer is back thereby
making his body more fragile and perhaps
more sensitive to blood loss but get
ready to have your mind blown because
there's research to suggest the exact
opposite that his cancer would have
incurred
his chances of survival there's actually
a significant amount of research that
suggests that people with pancreatic
cancer multiple myeloma and most
importantly for our purposes lung cancer
are all more likely to form blood clots
according to dr. Jean Conners at the
Dana Farber Cancer Institute for reasons
not quite known the normal human body
will keep a balance between kro clotting
and anti-clotting activity apparently
cancers excuse that balance in terms of
pro clotting increasing inflammation and
compression of blood vessels creating
more coagulation and actually lessening
internal bleeding long story short
there's actually a high probability that
Walt's cancer is limiting the amount of
blood he's losing in these crucial
minutes so we have not a full bullet but
a smaller piece of shrapnel entering
Walt's body in an area with
non-essential organs Walt's lotor about
the compound showing that the injury is
not really that critical in a situation
in which blood loss is slowed via only
an entry wound it being in the intestine
and Walt having cancer that brings us to
the final criteria of determining the
likelihood of survival speed at which
the victim gets medical attention if
Walt were alone somewhere in the New
Mexico desert this would be an
open-and-shut case he would have bled
out and died but the final shot shows us
the unit of police officers descending
on him almost immediately after he
collapses are they DEA Albuquerque PD if
we zoom in on the arm patch the shape
and color definitely indicate that it's
Albuquerque PD according to code zero
2-11 of the Albuquerque Police
Department procedural orders manual
quotes department policy is to ensure
that medical care is provided to
arrested persons intoxicated persons
when such care is needed based on
approved medical and legal procedures do
not only are the police obligated to
give Walt medical attention but let's
not forget that the Walter White case is
a national story they want Walt to see
trial they want Walt to live so that he
can confess to all the unsolved murders
he's been involved with
in their best interest to keep him alive
so that these cases can be concluded add
to that the fact that it's reasonable to
assume that there's a standard-issue
trauma kid and at least one of those cop
cars and most every police officer is
trained to dress a gunshot wound it's a
waltz bleeding would have been
significantly reduced as soon as a
minute after he collapsed and if you're
looking at this from a timeline
standpoint he literally just collapsed
we even see the police cars rushing past
seconds before he falls to the ground
and here's a big piece of evidence for
you why are the cops even there who
called them the pile of dead neo-nazis
certainly didn't Walt and Jesse didn't
do it the most likely case is that
someone nearby heard the m60 gunshots
and called the cops what that tells us
is that although we're never given a
real location for Jack's neo-nazi day
camp
it means we're close to civilization
based on the length of that last scene
it took 10 minutes for the cops to
arrive at the location that also means
that there's likely a hospital in that
vicinity so looking at all the pieces of
evidence considering the wound didn't
hit any vital organs was a smaller piece
of shrapnel didn't leave an exit wound
that clotting was increased due to
cancer and that help was on the scene
immediately after his collapse and Walt
got medical attention somewhere in the
realm of 20 minutes from the time he was
shot there's a high probability that
Walt survives this last scene of
Breaking Bad but you don't have to
believe me or all the research I did
just trust the creators of the show if
you look really really closely in that
final moment you see the officer reach
out and check for Walt's pulse and then
the scene cuts out before we get his
reaction we don't actually see the
results of that test think this was a
coincidence
heck no it was a purposely done move by
a creative team who fought through every
last detail of every shot in this show
what seemed like a clear-cut
cliche tending is actually open to
interpretation we just saw the easy
obvious answer but by doing the research
you see that there's a lot more
ambiguity to that final scene and that I
only have one thing to say yes science
and before I sign off if you want more
fun and fascinating Breaking Bad
analysis click on the I icon in the
upper right part of the screen to check
out my friends over at the wisecrack
channel who are doing an incredible
five-part series exploring the hidden
meaning of each season of Breaking Bad
relive all the magnets and tighty-whitey
goodness with their hilarious and
thought-provoking show earthling cinema
show your theorists pride tell a mad
Pat's ention I don't know leave some
sort of patroling comment about how Walt
isn't dead also if I was you I'd
probably subscribe while I was over
there but you know you're called your
prerogative and with that being said
remember that's just a theory
a film/tv theory and cut you know what
the coolest thing about all of this is
it leaves open the possibility of seeing
Walter White's trial appear on better
call Saul wouldn't that be incredible to
see the return of these characters ah
make it happen Vince Gilligan make it
happen please here click the bag of blue
meth to check out that Breaking Bad
miniseries I mentioned over on the
wisecrack channel or if you want
something truly scary click the
terminator
to see how we'll all be slaves to
computers within the next 30 years
fair warning the future gets intense and
you'll never look at your laptop the
same way again now if you'll excuse me
all this Breaking Bad talk has got me a
hankerin for some delicious fast food
chicken like El Pollo Loco or something
don't know why exactly huh strange
you